Ahh, France: the country where the far right
wing, as we know it today, was born.
Way before the financial crisis.
Way before Donald Trump became the president
of the US.
Way before Brexit, and the uprising of the
xenophobic parties in Europe...
Way way before all of that, France had an
extreme nationalist party, the NATIONAL FRONT,
and it had real chances to win elections.
Actually, in 2002 the rest of the political
players in the country, from the center-left
to the center-right, had to join forces in
order to just keep Jean Marie Le Pen from
becoming the President of France.
In April 2017, French people are going back
to the voting stations.
And a lot of people think that this is the
ultimate chance for the far right wing in
France.
The moment where the NATIONAL FRONT, with
MARINE LE PEN as its leader, can get the presidential
office once for all.
If this was the case, Marine Le Pen, who,
by the way, is the daughter of Jean Marie
Le Pen, has promised she will do everything
she can to take her country out of European
Union.
But not only that...
France is the second largest country in Continental
Europe.
A victory of the extreme right would be a
triumph for all far-right parties on the continent.
But wait just a minute...
Because now the question is…
Does Marine Le Pen have a REAL chance of winning
this election?
Can anyone stop her?
Today we will answer to all of this questions,
and we’re going to get to know, in-depth,
the history of the French extreme right: a
story that includes family wars, ego clashes
and… well… playmates.
So, let’s get into it.
THE LE PEN CLAN
The French extreme right wing has two ideological
grandparents:
Adolf Hitler and the OAS.
As you know, during World War II, Germans
invaded the North of France.
But the South, the so called “free zone”,
whose capital was the city of VICHY, was governed
by French politicians who supported the German
National Socialism too.
When the war ended, the new French President,
General Charles de Gaulle, executed the main
officials from Vichy.
But wait a minute, because still, there were
many other people that supported that collaborationist
government.
People that, even without having political
power, held the same principles and the same
ideals of the National Socialists from Nazi
Germany.
And many of them were in the army!
Decades later, in 1961, the French let their
most precious colony, Algeria, hold a self-determination
referendum.
As you can imagine, this was not good news
for all those far right wing extremist inside
of the French army.
This is how the OAS was born.
The OAS was a terrorist group whose main goal
was to end the Algerian attempt for independence.
So, did they succeed?
Actually not.
In 1962, Algeria became a sovereign state.
And then, the OAS changed their goals and
tried the kill the French President himself!
They thought De Gaulle was a traitor to the
country.
Fortunately, in 1965, the French police dismantled
the last cells of this group.
Just like what happened after the end of the
World War II though, jailing the hardliners
didn’t mean there were no more people supporting
the general cause.
France, the country of the liberty, equality
and fraternity, had a large amount of people
who hated the Algerians and had a nostalgia
for the Third Reich.
And this was the foundation that JEAN MARIE
LE PEN used to build, 10 years later, the
NATIONAL FRONT.
“It is the media who only talk about the
war, over and over.
Everyday we are reminded of what the war was:
The persecution of the Jews, the excessive
behaviour of the occupying forces and so on...”
The beginning of this party was not an easy
thing.
During the 1970s, the NATIONAL FRONT would
never get more than a 5% of the vote.
And Marie Le Pen himself suffered a terrorist
attack at his own house.
Now this is when the good part starts!
In 1977, the Le Pen family inherited, from
a fellow supporter, an entire palace.
The Montretout Palace.
Soon this would become the unofficial headquarters
of the National Front or… we might as well
say - the Le Pen family.
Yes, my friend, with this party, everything
stays in the family.
From the Montretout palace, Jean Marie organized
all those electoral campaigns that made him
the third biggest political force in France
at the end of the 80s.
Meanwhile, his daughter, Marine Le Pen, was
following him and learning the secrets and
the art of politics in order to become the
leader she is today.
Later, his granddaughter, MARION LE PEN, would
follow him too.
And she is now an MP in the French Parliament
and the rising star of the National Front.
Interestingly, though, even though his party
congratulates him as the champion of family
values…
Le Pen’s family is far from a happy one.
Yes, yes…
I know, here at VisualPolitik we don’t like
to gossip about the private life of anyone…
But in this case, it’s absolutely necessary
to understand the political life of this party!
As I said, in the 1980s, Jean Marie Le Pen,
whom we will call from now on, Le Pen senior,
was on fire.
nN every election, he was getting more votes
than the previous one.
In this moment, he hired a journalist to write
his own biography.
And, of course, he let him stay at his palace.
And guess what that journalist did?
Well, he seduced Le Pen´s wife.
Ohhh, but not only that...
These two lovers ran away from the palace.
And months later, Mrs. Le Pen was on the cover
of the French Playboy magazine.
And this is how the whole world discovered
the… err… more sensual side of the extreme
right wing.
PICTURES OF LE PEN IN PLAYBOY.
This caused a split in the family.
No matter how good the father was doing in
the elections, his daughter still grew more
and more distant from him.
But the real turning point in the Le Pen family
would come in the year 2002.
This was a year when France held presidential
elections.
And for the first time in history, Le Pen
went to the second round.
As you might know, the French electoral system
has two rounds.
When they are choosing a president, in the
first round they can choose from all the candidates,
however many that may be.
After this round, there is a second one where
only one of the two most successful candidates
can be chosen.
Well, in this 2002, the ones who made it the
the second round where Jacques CHIRAC, from
the center-right wing party, and Le Pen senior,
from the extreme right wing.
And now you might wonder…
How is that possible that they had two right
wing candidates?
Are there no liberals in France?
Well during these years, Le Pen learnt an
important lesson in politics: the idea of
the “captive voter”.
A voter that is going to find some principles
of the party attractive, no matter where they
stand on the political spectrum.
Le Pen stood for protectionism for French
companies, but also for French workers.
Do you remember the “America first” thing?
Yep, turns out that’s not Trumps invention.
It was used by Le Pen in the 1990s.
So in 2002, industrial cities like MARSEILLE,
who used to be the left wing strongholds,
voted for the National Front.
And this is why in this second round, those
who remained loyal to the Social democratic
party had to swallow their pride and vote
for Jaques Chirac, the center-right candidate.
Anything was better than the uprising of a
racist, extreme conservative like Le Pen.
And this is how the Le Pen family learned
a second lesson in politics: is not enough
getting accepted by your voters…
you also cannot be too scary to the others.
If your opposition are too frightened, they
might join forces to prevent you from getting
into the Presidential Palace.
MARINE VS.
JEAN MARIE VS.
MARION
Christmas was not a great time for the family
after 2002.
Marine Le Pen started her internal campaign
against her father.
Now, don’t forget that Jean Marie Le Pen
was a politician that ran for elections with
statements like this one:
“There has to be an authority, always, and
we believe that, in a household, the best
one to have this authority is the man.”
–Jean Marie Le Pen (Le droit ajourd´hui,
1979).
Nonetheless, Marine Le Pen was a woman ready
to have authority and modernise a political
party that would made Windows 95 look like
state of the art.
Unlike her father, Marine supported gay civil
unions and was against death penalty.
Even National Front voters could appreciate
these changes.
And this is why, in 2011, Le Pen junior took
her father’s place as the party leader.
Ahh, but things, they weren’t that easy...
“I wonder what motivated Marine and her
deputies in this offensive they launched against
me”.
Just think about it.
When you have been the founder and leader
of the French far right for 39 years, it's
not easy to put up with your daughter giving
you orders.
So, even though today, Jean Marie Le Pen is
the honorary president of the National Front…
he also votes as an independent at the European
Parliament.
“I campaigned not for Marine Le Pen, but
for Jean-Marie Le Pen and I won 33%.”
And guess who is his main supporter inside
of the party?
Surprise surprise!
Family business again, it’s his granddaughter,
MARION Le Pen, who is starting her own battle
against her aunt, Marine.
“I think that
Europe has made a mistake in the past.
They should have started cooperation and development
of relationships with Africa.
This way they would have fixed the people
in their own countries.”
In fact, the latest pollsters for this 2017
elections give her close to 25% of vote.
This makes her the first or the second biggest
candidate.
And in an election with 5 candidates, 25%
is a big thing.
It is almost certain that she will make it
into the second round.
But do consider that just because she is less
radical than her father this doesn’t mean
that Marine is a moderate.
Far from this in fact.
In her famous 144 points of her electoral
manifesto, Le Pen junior stands for closing
frontiers, massive deportations, the exit
of the European Union, and the return of the
French currency.
“I hold the same economic views as Vladimir
Putin.
This is true.
But this is nothing new either.”
Alright, enough, now you are probably wondering...
Well, can Le Pen actually become the new French
President?
Let’s address this question, with another
question...
WHO CAN STOP LE PEN?
For years, the center-right wing in France
saw how Le Pen could steal their votes.
Yes, it is true that a big share of the National
Front votes come from the left wing.
But in a this time of crisis, family values
and anti-immigrant sentiments are particularly
attractive for conservative voters.
So in 2016, the big party of the center-right,
THE REPUBLICANS, chose a candidate who also
put forward some of the proposals that made
Le Pen famous.
This man was FRANCOIS FILLON.
So, is that strategy working?
Well… apparently not.
Since Fillon became the party’s candidate,
Republicans have fallen on the polls and now
they are fighting for third position with
the far-left wing party of Jean Luc Melenchon.
Corruption, sex scandals and the fact that
voters prefer the original (Le Pen) to the
copy, has caused Fillon and the center-right
to fall into oblivion.
But there is still hope!
The battle is not over.
There is still a man ready to stop Le Pen’s
hurricane.
His name is EMMANUEL MARCON and he was the
finance minister during the government of
Manuel VALLS.
Alright, so is Emmanuel Marcon a socialist?
Hell no!
Macron is running in the elections as an independent.
Even Manuel Valls himself didn’t support
him in public until recently.
But what does Emmanuel Macron stand for?
Basically, just the opposite of Le Pen.
Macron wants to end the privileges and subsidies
that French companies get.
He wants to end the barriers that made it
impossible for the French to get a job.
And, of course, he is against discrimination
based on race or religion.
When it comes to the economy, he wants to
be the champion of deficit reduction and fiscal
responsibility.
And if this was not enough, one of his proposals
is to forbid high ranking officials to employ
their own family inside of the administration.
So... as you can see, he is the antithesis
of Marine Le Pen.
And surprise surprise, the latest polls suggest
he is slightly more popular than Marine Le
Pen - with over 25% of the expected.
And all of this, despite being an independent.
So he has a high chance of being the person
who will face Le Pen in the second round.
Or… maybe not?
There is a last variable we have to consider:
ABSTENTION.
Even if Macron has a lot of supporters, they
are simply not as motivated as those from
the Le Pen side.
So, for example, if during the second round,
the National Front could retain 90% of their
voters and Macron could only retain 40 or
50%, he would have difficulty winning
the presidency.
But this is our opinion, now we wanna hear
yours.
Can Macron beat Le Pen?
Could any of the other candidates make a surprise
resurgence during the elections?
Please, leave your answer on the comment section
below, we’d love to hear from you.
And don’t forget we publish brand new videos
every Monday and every Thursday, so don’t
forget to subscribe so you won’t miss any
future videos.
And if you liked this video, give us a thumbs
up.
And… as always, I’ll see you next time.